so what I wanted to do here was have a
discussion about Miles Morales and what
I'm hoping is that by the end of this
video you'll have an understanding of
who Miles Morales is and why Miles
Morales was so important not only for
existing comic book fans but for new
comic book readers as well
so in 2000 writer Brian Michael Bendis
editor-in-chief Joe Quesada and Marvel
president bill Jimmy's we're looking at
the idea of rebooting classic Marvel
characters and were to give them a more
modern approach and to make them more
appealing to younger audiences at the
time because of his popularity Marvel
first chose to launch the ultimate
universe using spider-man in the hopes
that by way of being the flagship Marvel
character and he would be able to draw
in readers who were previously on the
fence about purchasing this new line of
comics in this new universe both major
and minor changes were made to the
character of Peter Parker the first was
that he was written as having received
his powers due to a bite from a
genetically engineered spider rather
than a radioactive spider and the second
was at his character worked as a
webmaster for the Daily Bugle rather
than a photographer these changes
combined with Venice's skillful writing
of Mary Jane Watson Gwen Stacy Aunt May
and Uncle Ben led ultimate spider-man to
become a critical success however by
2011 Brian Michael Bendis was looking at
ways to remove Peter Parker from the
role of spider-man and introduce a new
character to take his place
in 2011 prior to the death of Peter
Parker Brian Michael Bendis and artist
Sarah Pacelli created Miles Morales and
while President Barack Obama actor
Donald Glover and Peter Parker were
inspirations for the creation of Miles
Benison Bocelli wanted their creation to
be able to stand on his own two feet
separate from any existing and popular
african-americans at even Peter Parker
himself to accomplish this Myles was
created as being half african-american
and half Hispanic and in continuing with
the trend of creating characters using
modern awareness miles was presented as
a part of urban culture with these same
struggles of most modern kids from these
areas and his initial introduction
Marvel established that Miles dealt with
neighborhood crime bullying and the
desire for others to bring him into
their environment furthermore while
miles gained his powers in the same form
as Peter Parker in that he was bitten by
a genetically engineered spider
unlike Peter Parker Miles didn't want to
become a superhero miles upbringing by
his father combined with society's
overall dislike of superheroes led miles
to attempt to cast this role aside even
going as far as to not assist Peter
Parker during the death of spider-man
event something that would actually
haunt him on a personal level and even
become his inspiration for undertaking
the mantle of spider-man after Peter
Parker had died during a conversation I
had with Sal at Comic pop he threw out
what I consider to be the best analogy
of the comparison between Miles Morales
and Peter Parker from the ultimate
universe if Uncle Ben was Peter Parker's
reason for becoming spider-man then
Peter Parker was Miles Morales Uncle Ben
and following the introduction of Miles
Morales into the role of spider-man
Marvel provided readers with a
comic-book comparison to what was
happening in the real world the idea of
Peter Parker being removed from the role
of spider-man even in this new universe
was something that split the core fan
base directly down the middle
traditionalists of spider-man history
felt that Peter Parker was the one true
spider-man and a cast someone in his
place was either a publicity stunt or
bad taste however newer readers who were
introduced to Marvel by way of the
Ultimate Universe wanted something fresh
and new that actually broke away from
the tradition of spider-man
ethology these conflicting sentiments
were reflected in the comics when miles
donned a variant of the spider-man
costume following the death of Peter
Parker and that some characters shunned
his efforts as disrespectful to the
memory of spider-man while others urged
him to continue however virtually all
critics of Miles Morales were silenced
when wawel created a story titled
spider-man where Peter Parker from the
mainstream earth-616 universe actually
met Miles Morales his Ultimate Universe
counterpart where previously the two had
never met and with it being unknown if
they ever would meet marvel established
by way of miles receiving Peter Parker's
blessing that miles was here to stay and
that even if Peter Parker in the
Ultimate Universe were to return he
would not undertake the mantle of
spider-man furthermore where the series
initially had skeptics and while never
selling enough issues to break the
top-25 comics list following this story
Miles Morales was extremely well
received by his readers and by multiple
media outlets and was considered to be a
breath of fresh air in a history that
was beginning to grow stale in addition
due to the reception of Miles Morales
and the desire of Marvel to shake up
their varying titles and teams following
the secret Wars event Miles Morales was
officially announced to take over the
role of spider-man from Peter Parker as
part of the all new Marvel Universe
going forward with that being said we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end and I will catch you guys
later
prease